When Darwin traveled to the Galapagos,
he saw finches with beaks of different
shapes and sizes, exquisitely adapted
to feed from differently shaped flowers.
From these observations, he established
the theory of evolution. What is
evolution? Let's explore this concept
with an example. How did animals adapt
their eyesight when they left water to
live on dry land? Tiktaalik is thought
to represent the evolutionary
transition from fish to amphibians,
about 375 million years ago. As we know
from swimming underwater and opening
our own eyes, images are quite blurry.
Humans have not evolved to see well
underwater. The same is true for
aquatic animals. They can't see well
with the eye-air interface on dry land.
Without good eyesight, protecting
oneself and one's family, attracting a
mate, and finding food are difficult
and life threatening. These
difficulties are called selective
pressures, and represent the driving
force of evolution.
How do we go from a water dwelling
animal to one that can see on land?
First, random genetic mutations and DNA
create diversity in the shapes and
properties of eyes. These variations
may be beneficial, neutral or
detrimental. The beneficial ones are
key.
The ancestors of Tiktaalik, with
improved eyesight on land, have access
to a tremendous bounty of food. They
grow more rapidly and have more
offspring that all bear the mutation
with improved eyesight. At each
generation, more genetic diversity
arises, and the selective pressure of
finding mates, avoiding disasters, and
getting to good food favors the fittest,
that is the Tiktaaliks with better
eyesight. In this way, the eyesight on
land gets better and better. This is
evolution. A new population has evolved
with a well adapted and improved trait;
the fittest survive.